there's 21 strategies of habit change
and they're all very useful but there's
one that is the most fun strategy and
that is the strategy of treats now it's
very important to know what a treat is a
treat is not a reward it's not something
that you get because you earned it you
don't have to justify it a treat is
something that you get because you want
it and treats may sound like kind of a
selfish self indulgent strategy to use
but treats are very important because
the fact is treats help us get
self-command they energize us they make
us feel comforted and cared for and when
we are like that then we can ask more of
ourselves in other ways so when we give
more to ourselves we can ask more from
ourselves and you often hear people when
justifying a bad habit with like I need
it I've earned it I deserve it so and a
lot of times people go for unhealthy
treats because they feel like they need
to recharge their battery and so they
use an unhealthy treat but if you load
yourself with healthy treats if you have
a large lot of items to choose from and
it's not as easy to come up with a long
list of healthy treats as you think then
you're going to be able to recharge your
battery and there are some treats that
are often unhealthy food treats
technology treats and shopping treats a
lot of times these can become unhealthy
treats very quickly so they if you use
them you have to be very mindful and use
them judiciously and know that they're
not going to spiral out of control for
you you know giving yourself a brownie
is probably not the best treat but
things like wearing perfume or buying
new music or you know fer therapy a
friend of mine has for therapy which is
when she just spent a half an hour of
like playing with her dog if you have a
long list of these healthy treats then
when you have that feeling like I need
it I deserve it I've earned it then you
can give yourself a healthy treat and
that way you keep yourself command high
you